uh thank god for ricky gervais
the first time i ever met you was at the
golden globes yeah you came over to uh i
did you do not remember that
there's no way
in my defense i was loads of people
coming over and it was crazy i didn't
think we were going to standing by
yourself when i came over
people say is there anything you
shouldn't joke about and i i don't think
there is i just think it depends what
the joke is i think comedy comes from a
good or a bad place and i was just
teasing them you know and it wasn't a
room full of wounded soldiers
these are the richest most privileged
people in the world
talking of all you perverts it was a big
year
it was a big year for pedophile movies
um
surviving r kelly
leaving neverland
two popes
shut up
shut up i don't care i don't care
first joke i thought of when i said yes
to host the golden globes i wanted to
come out and say
welcome to the golden globes why is this
show like a female elephant
it too has a massive
[Laughter]
in fact the first time i did it people
were like why is he why is he being
nasty to all these lovely important
people and by the fifth time was going
yeah go on give it to him yeah these
people are sick of like celebrities sort
of virtual signal and then telling them
what to do and you know these th
it's so funny the last few years
i've seen it i've seen the change where
you know ordinary people were getting
sick of multi-millionaires telling them
to recycle when everyone knew they were
they were flying around in yeah private
jets and limos and uh
i think that that was the peak of it you
know with the last golden globes i did
where people just got sick why they were
why are we yeah why why why are we
listening to this watching people with
everything you know it's it's it's
nonsense if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your god
so
but someone must read the script before
you go on um it's uh
i do it i say i'm going to say what i
want i don't have to rehearse and they
and they say that's fine but i do have
to tell a lawyer it just before i go on
yeah
okay does the lawyer make you change
anything or no because i i know i know
the law
who is harder to manage a group of dogs
in the park a group of children on your
show or perhaps a bunch of celebrities
at the golden globes
you've got to get their attention at the
golden globes
does that you know i i have to go out
and say shut up listen and as long as
there's a threat that i could pick on
one of them then they listen they're
great yeah um oh the golden globes there
you go
oh who cares look at them all
look at them all
they were asking for it with their good
skin and hair
[Laughter]
on a serious note just looking at all
the faces
here reminds me of some of the great
work that's been done this year
by cosmetic surgeons
you know we haven't seen yours uh really
around since the golden globes where
you're low profile yeah well they they
attacked you but they said that you were
mean and rude and you were surprised at
that
what it was about let me just read one
of the things that i'm being rude i'm
surprised they attacked me for it though
yeah exactly
let me read one thing they thought was
mean and we'll decide whether it was
meaning okay
um
referring referring to sex in the city
too i said i was sure the golden globe
would go to the team that airbrushed
that poster there were a lot of big
films that didn't get nominated this
year nothing for sex in the city too um
no i was sure the golden globe for
special effects would go to the team
that airbrushed that poster um
what
little sexist no it's not why is it
sexist well because the girl is saying
that the girls are older and they need
to be here no i don't know no i think
they look great at their age why hide it
oh i don't think i don't think that you
lose your sensuality or beauty because
you hit 53. i'm saying why are they
hiding it oh i see it
okay you must were you in the audience
for any of ricky's school of globes
several times
it was a little bit i think it cuts to
you in one of them i think when you talk
about jeffrey epstein
to me
[Laughter]
you could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife instead of watching
this show that that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer and it's still more
fun than this okay
spoiler alert um season two is on the
way so in the end he obviously didn't
kill himself
just like jeffrey epstein
shut up i know he's your friend but i
don't care
[Applause]
it's always lovely to get
nominated and awarded but if you take it
too seriously you're on a slippery slope
if you really think that you know you're
you're anything special when you win an
award you just won an award that's all
there was it was you know out of a few
people and you won the awards so what
yeah you know it's same with these
honors lists when i see
actors and people getting you know mbes
and obs and
for doing some what they loved that
should go to nurses and soldiers and
people who have really sacrificed all
their life i just i you know don't get
me started don't get me started on
celebrities
it is an honor to be here um in a room
full of what i consider to be the most
important people on the planet actors
they're just
they're just better than ordinary people
aren't they that's no
we all know that um
imagine a world without actors oh god it
doesn't bear think about imagine if i
ever went on strike oh
what would we do you couldn't replace
them you couldn't replace them with any
other profession lawyers or doctors can
you imagine a real surgeon doing what
hugh laurie does in-house it would be
pathetic
he'd be all over the place and go where
do i stand how's my american accent
what's my lines you know hugh with the
aid of coaches i can eventually learn
his lines while saving lives he's a
genius
but actors aren't just loved here in
hollywood they i loved the world over
because they're recognizable you can be
anywhere you could be in the third world
okay and you get a glimpse of a
hollywood star and it makes you feel
better okay you could be a little a
little child a little asian child with
no possessions and no money but you get
a you see a picture of angelina jolie
and you think mummy
[Music]
this one i didn't do
because again you'll see why i didn't do
it
um
i was gonna come up and say
this year
the awards
are all about diversity
our presenters represent all races
religions and sexualities
tonight we've got bill cosby harvey
weinstein and kevin spacey
and to be ultra inclusive this year i've
asked all the presenters what their
preferred pronouns are so please welcome
hair mel gibson
here's all the jokes i wrote from
the golden globes
some i didn't use
that one i didn't use because it's
it's
no it's not
um
yeah
there's one
uh somehow i didn't use because i got a
couple of jokes for saying so i only
used one uh
[Music]
it was a joke about the irishman
the main cast we're all in their
seventies
uh al pacino being the father figure at
79 apparently he spent the entire shoot
telling joe pesci
to get his hair cut and turn his music
down
sweet bit lame not not punchy enough
um
what else
um
right here's one that i thought wasn't
quite right because he was being honored
um i thought like tom hanks being
awarded the cecil b demille award
uh
for basically being the nicest man
in
hollywood
no one has a bad word to say about him
and i can see why
he's he's such a considerate bloke
he even folds his own sheet after clan
meetings
even when he's off his head on cocaine
and meth
now
i don't think that would have calmed
down very well
um
uh
here's another one i thought i shouldn't
do because she was being honored um
uh
ellen
uh getting the
award
uh
uh even though she's the nicest
woman in america
she even felt the wrath of the social
justice warriors when she was spotting
cozying up to george w
one headline said ellen loves bush
we know
well you can see why didn't do those
jokes
well i'd have i don't know better than
that i'd have worked on them but
you know